[Musik]
eine stadt in größter sorge die zahl der
korona toten allein in new york city ist
höher als die in ganz deutschland und
die lage wird immer schwieriger das
virus und das wetter zu hause bleiben
abstand halten wenn draußen die sonne
scheint eine herausforderung für das
ganze land
[Musik]
abschied von den toten china erinnert an
die vielen opfer der pandemie
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
samstag guten abend in hallen
es ist eine welt die kaum noch
wiederzuerkennen ist der gesamte globus
im griff des virus mit ländern in denen
die infektionen rasant steigen gemessen
in mehr oder weniger genauen zahlen und
mit ländern in denen wir annehmen müssen
dass sie ebenso rasant steigen aber
niemand misst und testet es sind bilder
von historischer dimension
die welt steht still egal ob bukarest
rumänien oder addis abeba äthiopien
straßen plätze parks gesperrt strände
wie sydney bondi beach zu die
grabeskirche in jerusalem
der basar von damaskus konzeption in den
chilenischen anden die welt hält den
atem an und mediziner kämpfen um das
leben von schwer erkrankten allein hier
in new york haben sich mittlerweile mehr
als 100.000 menschen infiziert und das
sind nur die bekannten fälle el mati
wissen es ist einer der gefährlichsten
orte in den usa die kurve 19 stationen
im mai/juni des krankenhaus in brooklyn
es fehlt an platz an ausrüstung an
personal mehr als 300 tote an einem tag
allein in new york city
die rettungskräfte versuchen ihren
kollegen mut zu machen ihnen zu danken
der staat new york versucht verstärkung
für sie zu bekommen aus allen
landesteilen aber sie zweifeln dass
hilfe naht weil es an schutzkleidung
mangelt es geht um leben und tod jedes
krankenhaus in new york in dem land
sollte haben was es braucht der
gouverneur von new york wie die
nationalgarde einsetzen um
beatmungsgeräte zwangsweise aus anderen
teilen des bundesstaates in die
krankenhäuser zu bringen die sie
brauchen
bin ich bereit dazu um leben zu retten
absolut immerhin bekommt new york heute
1000 badens maschinen aus china eine
spende und aus oregon 140 geräte als
leiter jeder einwohner hier soll nun
maske tragen auch die regierung in
washington empfiehlt das weil es
hinweise auf übertragung des virus durch
art
der oberste arzt amerikas erklärt wie
man sich aus irgendwas eine maske selbst
bastelt die supermacht ist nicht in der
lage genug nachschub zu produzieren und
der präsident will nicht mitmachen
das ist freiwillig du musst es nicht
machen sie empfehlen es vorübergehend
freiwillig ich werde es wohl nicht aber
mit der zahl der infektionen und der
todesopfer wächst auch die einsicht in
new york folgen viele der empfehlung und
tragen masken
wir gehen live nach new york city zu
johannes hano johannes morgen ist der
tag der entscheidung sagt der
bürgermeister was meint er damit
naja new york erwartet für ende der
woche den höhepunkt der krise und die
krankenhäuser stoße und ihre
kapazitätsgrenze und der bürgermeister
hat sie mit einem dramatischen appell an
alle new yorker gewendet er hat gesagt
ich rufe euch zu den waffen jeder der
irgendetwas tun kann der helfen kann der
soll sich jetzt melden sofort und
freiwillig und ich habe gerade eine
nachricht von einem freund bekommen der
orthopäde ist und der hat gesagt dazu
ebenso einen einsatz bekommen um sich
montagmorgen um 6 oder ein krankenhaus
zu melden und der gouverneur hat immer
noch etwas anderes getan hat so genannte
executives order erlassen das heißt er
hat polizei und sicherheitskräfte
ermächtigt schutzausrüstung einzuziehen
hat gesagt wie bürgerbus morgen habt ihr
noch zeit freiwillig alles abzuliefern
was ihr habt schutzausrüstung masken
willen aber auch beatmungsgeräte und
wenn er das nicht macht dann wird die
polizei kommen und alles abholen so wie
es im moment aussieht macht new york hat
gerade eine medizinische
generalmobilmachung vorsicht das wird
jetzt sehr hart die nächste woche
johannes vielen dank gleich nach und zum
19 20 die reportage von johannes hano
big apple in not new yorks kampf gegen
korona außerdem können sie sich
natürlich über die zdf heute app
jederzeit informieren zum beispiel mit
einem live blog
die zahlen für deutschland steigen
ebenfalls aber es verdichten sich auch
die hinweise dass sich das virus bei uns
langsamer ausbreitet details hat antoine
kuscheln
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand
heute 18
30 92.000 150 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt die dunkelziffer könnte nach
experten schätzungen fünf bis zehnmal
höher sein
die zahl der todesfälle in verbindung
mit 19 beträgt aktuell 1330 26.400 sind
als genesen erfasst die tatsächliche
zahl dürfte aber weit höher sein da
nicht immer getestet wird ob eine person
geheilt ist entscheidend für die dynamik
der epidemie ist der zeitraum in dem
sich die zahl der erkrankten verdoppelt
die politik der kontakt beschränkungen
soll diesen wert nach oben treiben die
ausbreitung also langsamer werden
anfangs waren es rund zwei tage
bundesweit sind es weiter neun tage
die bundesregierung will lockerungen
erst dann erwägen wenn ein wert von etwa
14 tagen erreicht wird das weitgehende
kontaktverbot in deutschland gilt weiter
um ausflügler fernzuhalten sperrt der
landkreis stade in niedersachsen
die elbdeiche auch bad urach am fuß der
schwäbischen alb hat reagiert die
parkplätze rund um den berühmten
wasserfall reduziert in berlin zieht es
besonders familien in die parks das ist
hier erlaubt es gilt allerdings ein
mindestabstand von fünf metern zur
nächsten familie eine herausforderung
die es überall in deutschland gibt
tolles wetter aber eben nicht die option
darauf so zu reagieren wie man das
normalerweise tun würde
carsten behrendt ist für uns live im
park am gleisdreieck in berlin carsten
guten abend wie läuft das aktuell in
berlin
christian mein eindruck ist es läuft
auch deswegen weil die menschen noch mal
stoppen können auch mal zur ruhe kommen
können in den parks wir sehen hier
hinter mir das auf den treppen und auf
der wiese sind kleine gruppen
wahrscheinlich alles wohngemeinschaften
die hier beisammen stehen die sich auf
der wiese ausruhen und in den parks hier
in der stadt wo ich unterwegs war habe
ich das immer wieder gesehen das war gut
gefüllt aber nicht überfüllt und die
polizei mit der ich gerade noch
gesprochen habe die mit 500 beamten
extra die regularien kontrolliert sagte
es gab vereinzelt verstöße
in der regel mit einer kleinen ansprache
und erinnerung an die regeln hat es dann
auch funktioniert dass sich die menschen
dann wieder dran gehalten haben als die
mehrheit hält sich an die regeln der
berliner weg den kann man so ein
bisschen beschreiben mit zuckerbrot und
peitsche es gibt die strengen die
strengen bußgelder wie an vielen anderen
orten in deutschland auch aber eben auch
die lockerung für die parks denn
vergangene woche war es noch verboten
mal anzuhalten auf eine bank sich zu
setzen oder auf eine wiese das hat man
jetzt geändert und wohl auch deswegen
weil die perspektive dieser maßnahmen
doch noch länger ist als also die wir
noch länger aufrecht erhalten als
bislang gedacht darauf hat der berliner
innensenator und auch jetzt der
regierende bürgermeister die berliner
vorbereitet dass es eben keinen thaksin
nahe zukunft geben wird wo alles wieder
normal so wie vorher laufen wird der
berliner weg carsten behrendt herzlichen
dank
und jetzt geht es um eine freundschaft
die als felsenfest gilt eigentlich und
um die sich das saarland jetzt große
sorgen macht saarbrückens
oberbürgermeister wand zwischen
deutschen und franzosen verschlechterte
sich die stimmung zunehmend und zwar auf
beiden seiten der grenze viele übergänge
sind seit wochen gesperrt umwege und
kontrollen raubend zeit eine
herausforderung für all die die jenseits
der grenze arbeiten oder familie haben
und eine harte probe für die region die
jetzt erlebt wie der ton zwischen einst
guten nachbarn immer rauer wird susanne
freitag auf der einen seite petrocelli
co at 19 risikogebiet laut ärgerten auf
der anderen brückenseite großrosseln
saarland nur berufspendler wie jessica
bücher dürfen nach deutschland vor zwei
wochen wollte michael bieber seine frau
von der arbeit abholen sie hat keinen
führerschein
es kam zum streit mit der polizei der
polizist wurde plötzlich laut sehr
aggressiv ich habe ihn gebeten ruhig zu
bleiben und da hat er du dreckiger
franzose zu mir gesagt
auch in frankreich anfeindungen gegen
deutsche vor allem im netz das geht sehr
viel gruppen werden sich die hauspreise
anziehen wo jetzt im moment ob bei
facebook
christoph arendt ist abgeordneter der
französischen nationalversammlung er
wohnt in petit roussel seit der
grenzschließung haben in dutzende mails
und anrufe erreicht
man hat französischen aus deutschen
geschäften verwiesen französischen
fabrikarbeitern in deutschland wurde
verboten sich draußen ein sandwich zu
kaufen solche sachen versöhnungsgespräch
auf der brücke deutsche und französische
politiker der region versuchen die wogen
zu glätten
frankreich wünscht sich dass die
grenzübergänge durchlässiger werden
manche pendler müssen über 60 kilometer
umweg zur arbeit fahren darunter auch
medizinpersonal das in deutschland
arbeitet es sind schwierige zeiten
insofern muss man abwägen für mich und
für den bundesinnenminister geht
infektionsschutz forum wegen eine
persönliche youtube botschaft vom
saarländischen bürgermeistern an ihre
französischen kollegen die deutsch
französische freundschaft muss stärker
sein als ein virus
elf millionen menschen leben in hahn wo
die korona katastrophe begann und sie
haben schlimmes mitgemacht viele haben
angehörige und freunde verloren alle
bewohner mussten zwei monate in strenger
isolation überstehen
jetzt sagt chinas führung sie habe das
virus im griff ingo hahn hoffen sie dass
das wirklich stimmt und gedenken der
toten stephanie schöneborn berichtet
china hält inne
drei minuten landesweit im gedenken an
die opfer des corona virus vom
präsidenten in peking bis zu den
medizinischen einsatzkräften in wo haben
dort wo das virus die meisten opfer
forderte
seit dem frühen morgen bringen menschen
blumen zu den krankenhäusern um vor
allem der ärzte und schwestern zu
gedenken
ich bin selber teil des medizinischen
personals ich verstehe wie hat die zeit
war vor allem von unserem lokalen
mediziner sind viele gestorben
heute sind sie helden und märtyrer und
doch ist das gedenken an die toten
auch eine klage in diesem krankenhaus in
johannstadt einer der ärzte
der vor dem virus warnte und dafür von
den chinesischen behörden bestraft wurde
wir haben ein sehr langes gedächtnis wir
haben im februar den toten gedacht und
jetzt im april wieder und wir werden sie
nicht vergessen
ingo hahn kehrt ein wenig leben zurück
und doch die ausgangssperre erlaubt die
menschen noch immer nur alle 3 tage raus
zu gehen seit knapp zweieinhalb monaten
sind die menschen hier in quarantäne
im ausnahmezustand die läden machen
endlich langsam wieder auf wir können
auch einfach nicht mehr geschlossen
bleiben
wir können uns das nämlich nicht mehr
leisten so sehr die regierung auch
normalität verkünden will
die desinfektions fahrzeuge bleiben im
einsatz die meisten geschäfte sind noch
geschlossen und die angst vor einer
zweiten infektionswelle ist spürbar
unser china korrespondent rolf roller
ist live in johann wolf guten abend eine
lange ausgangssperre wir haben es
gesehen die jetzt langsam gelockert wird
bitte beschreiben sie doch mal ihre
eindrücke heute in dieser
aus der das virus k
ja wir sind heute den ganzen tag durch
wo angefahren und was mich doch noch mal
sehr beeindruckt hat ist wie gigantisch
groß diese stadt des elf bis zwölf
millionen menschen sollen hier leben und
die hat man wirklich für zwei monate in
quarantäne gesteckt daran sieht man wie
massiv die maßnahmen der chinesischen
regierung waren die wünsche der menschen
sind eigentlich sehr ähnlich den
wünschen die wir auch in deutschland
haben sie sehen sich nach normalität sie
haben ein wenig angst vor der situation
da ist eben die frau die einen kleinen
stand hat und schweinefleisch verkauft
aber die kunden kommen nicht und rechts
und links von ihr haben die anderen
geschäfte entweder geschlossen oder sind
schon pleitegegangen
und da ist eben auch dieses
nachbarschafts komitee das genau
aufpasst wer ihm die wohnsiedlung
reingeht und der wieder rausgeht und
jeder wie gesagt wird weil ihm fieber
gemessen und er wird ab gesprüht mit
desinfektionsmittel weil man eben angst
hat dass das virus wieder kommt fazit
johann ist eigentlich eine stadt wie
viele städte auf der welt die menschen
haben angst und sie sehen sich nach
normalität sagt er voller live in doha 0
vielen dank in deutschland sind die
korona fälle unterschiedlich verteilt
während es im norden weniger infizierte
gibt kämpft der südwesten mit hohen
zahlen auch wegen der nähe zu österreich
und italien viele vogel im ihren
skiferien dorthin und infizierten sich
so sind einzelne krankenhäuser voll
belegt mit intensivpatienten neue
patienten müssen in andere kliniken
gebracht werden
doch das ist kompliziert ein zentrales
verteilsystem gibt es nicht
eva schiller und kleist berichten
krisensitzung der intensivmediziner im
landkreis esslingen die infektionszahlen
sind hier besonders hoch immer wieder
kommt es zu engpässen bei beatmungs
plätzen heißt bisher ärzte müssen
verzweifelt herumtelefonieren eine
andere deutsche klinik suchen die
schwerkranke patienten schnell
übernehmen kann
das sei ineffektiv und gefährlich
angesichts steigender zahlen
ein hotspot bundesland zu läuft dann
brauchen wir dringend die möglichkeit
strukturiert so wie jetzt in baden
württemberg bundesweit zu verlegen
deutschlandweit sind etwa 60 prozent der
intensivbetten belegt die verteilung
unterschiedlich im süden sind kliniken
überlastet im norden viele betten frei
der bund müsse reagieren die verteilung
rechtzeitig übernehmen
wir brauchen wir und die und die
ressource erster es kümmert sich jemand
darum und drittens die transportmittel
werden bereitgestellt denn es sind ja in
der regel auch patienten die einen
erhöhten betreuungsbedarf haben wir
fragen gesundheitsminister sparen
ob eine bundesweite verteilstelle
geplant ist es ist richtig dass die
intensivmediziner darauf hinweisen und
wir sind auch in gesprächen mit den
ländern wie mit den
rettungsorganisationen dass wir
natürlich auch kapazitäten haben müssen
und ein bundesweit verlegen zu können im
fall der fälle
der fall der fälle könnte schon nächste
woche eintreten meinen sie in esslingen
kliniken an der belastungsgrenze sollten
jetzt menschen verlegen um platz zu
schaffen für ständig neu ankommende
corona patienten für spargel und
erdbeerbauern gibt es eine gute
nachricht rumänien erlaubt saison
arbeitern per sondergenehmigung die
ausreise
sie können per flugzeug nach deutschland
kommen obwohl rumänien die
flugverbindungen ins ausland eigentlich
gestrichen hatte die bundesregierung hat
ihrerseits die einreise von 40.000
erntehelfern pro monat genehmigt
in frankreich hat ein mann mit einem
messer zwei menschen getötet und
mindestens vier verletzt
der vorfall ereignete sich in der
südfranzösischen stadt marseille bei
lyon in einer einkaufsstraße laut medien
wurde der mutmaßliche täter festgenommen
er habe keine papiere bei sich gehabt
aber angegeben sudan asse zu sein
welches motiv er hatte werde geprüft
teilt die antiterror staatsanwaltschaft
mit die britische labour partei hat
einen neuen chef kirsch stammer früher
anwalt für menschenrechte und später
staatsanwalt übernimmt die führung der
opposition im landtag sprach von einem
privileg gut 56 prozent der
parteimitglieder hatten online und per
brief für ihn gestimmt
seine wahl gilt als klare abkehr vom
links kurs seines vorgängers unter dem
sich die partei mehr und mehr
zerstritten hatte jeremy corbijn war
nach dem historisch schlechten ergebnis
bei der letzten parlamentswahl
zurückgetreten und jetzt geburtstage
jubiläen und ähnliches wir in diesen
zeiten etwas zu feiern hat macht nochmal
ganz besondere erfahrungen
man muss sich mit glückwünschen aus der
ferne anfreunden und mit semi
originellen geschenken wie klopapier
oder ravioli dosen
es geht aber auch anders wie wär's mit
einem ganz persönlichen konzert jetzt
den edinger und ina baltes zeigen wie es
geht julian adler ist sänger seine fans
sieht er gerade nicht live konzerte darf
er auch nicht geben
doch über seine kamera nimmt er jetzt in
seinem wohnzimmer aus musikalische
berufs botschaften auf die bei ihm
bestellt werden weil es einfach schön
ist die leute jetzt mit was zu
beschenken was sie sich so gar nicht
gedacht hätten was eben eine
überraschung ist die idee mit den
überraschenden grüßen an freunde und
familie hatten miriam schütt und
marilena amazon
sie betreiben eigentlich ein
internetportal für wohnzimmer konzerte
jetzt in zeiten von corona kann man über
ihr portal musik grüße bestellen viele
ihrer künstler machten gerne bei dem
projekt mit alle zwei tage besuchen
kommt wie gefahren habe muss doch auch
zum dreißigsten geburtstag hast du dir
bestimmt auch anders vorgestellt
die musiker sind schreiben uns teilweise
auch das emotionale sich darüber bringen
darf dass sie selbst total gerührt sind
für künstler wie julian adler aber nicht
nur eine schöne beschäftigung sondern
auch eine zusätzliche und wichtige
einnahmen
für mich fällt natürlich auch jetzt
total viel weg total viele konzerte aber
also ich habe gerade das gefühl so in
der kunst bewegt sich jetzt total viel
momentan und gerade eben so eine aktion
zeigt dann ja auch die leute sind
flexibel
musik verbindet in einer zeit in der man
eigentlich vermeiden soll
sie spendet trost und hilft gegen
einsamkeit und lagerkoller
[Musik]
sonnenschein haben wir schon jetzt wird
es dazu auch noch wärmer mehr gleich von
ostend ali zum wetter so wir haben sehr
viel weniger sport als gewohnt in dieser
sendung ich vermisse die kolleginnen und
kollegen hier nebenan
aber wir haben ein fernseh tipp nachher
nach dem heute journal im aktuellen
sportstudio die reportage corona und der
patient sport darin geht es auch um den
überlebenskampf der kleineren profi
fußballclubs es lohnt sich
wir sind auch morgen wieder für sie da
zur gewohnten zeit von und sagen danke
für das große interesse und wo immer es
geht machen sie sich einen angenehmen
samstagabend tschüss
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter dieser tage gibt es aber kaum
kondensstreifen am himmel eine gute
gelegenheit für wissenschaftler
umfangreiche messungen vorzunehmen
ganz ohne die störenden abgase ja und so
bleibt es auch in den nächsten tagen
wir haben es hier mit einem
umfangreichen hoch zu tun und das
erwärmt die warme luft noch weiter und
so wird es auch in den nächsten nächten
nicht mehr ganz so eisig kalt der
kommenden nacht gibt es kaum wolken
meist stern klar wo dazu temperaturen
von minus ein grad im osten und minus
vier grad am alpenrand 6 grad an der
nordsee morgen scheint die sonne den
ganzen tag bei einem leichtem bis
mäßigem südostwind und die temperaturen
erreichen schon mal werte im westen von
bis zu 22 grad und 15 grad an der ostsee
meist liegen wir bei über der 15 grad
marke die kommenden tage werden noch
wärmer am montag bis 24 grad vor allem
im westen und diese wärme die den sich
dann allmählich nach osten und nach
süden aus und auch mittwoch zieht es so
ähnlich aus damit ein schöner abend